hey what's up everybody i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
and today is september 30th 2021 do me a
favor i haven't told you this in a while
would you share our videos if you enjoy
them would you subscribe to our channel
if you find this thing valuable and
would you tap the notification bell if
you actually want to see when we post
new content you'd be doing me a solid
and i know it would make you feel good
we are doing a reuben report locals uh q
a today we got dozens and dozens of
questions this morning i only take
questions from our local community
members
so of course you can always sign up and
join us there for early video and add
free stuff and a whole bunch more at
reubenport.locals.com and we are going
to do one story before we get to that
this lunatic congresswoman sheila
jackson lee these people just lie
about everything and you're not going to
believe it we have now
using the latest and greatest technology
we have something called video
to prove that they're liars so they say
crazy things and now using technology we
can expose them as the complete and
utter frauds that they are uh before we
get to that guys i want to talk to you
about bonner private wine it's a little
early to be drinking for me but i've got
a bottle right here do you guys enjoy a
glass of wine with dinner maybe while in
the backyard entertaining friends i
certainly do well let me tell you about
one of my best kept secrets the world's
first extreme altitude wine club my
friends over at
freethinkerwine.com or a group of
americans who got tired of those flimsy
wines you find at most supermarkets you
know the kind the cheap throat burning
reds and the syrupy yellow whites they
set out on a journey miles away from
civilization and nine thousand feet into
the sky to find some of the world's most
remote wines and they nearly died trying
seriously pop open one of their bottles
of malbec you're gonna get some notes of
blackberry leather cherry smoke and a
little dark cherry that's two times i
said cherry there it's a lot of cherry
plus if you love steak and barbecue like
i do these wines make a great pairing
try them with the smoked tri tip that's
what we knocked out the other night
today you can be one of the first to try
these extr extreme altitude wines visit
freethinkerwine.com and you'll get 50
off the wine and 50 off shipping no
middleman no inflated prices no promo
code needed
just visit freethinkerwine.com that's
free thinkorwine.com and now back to me
all right wine bottle you go there okay
so one of the things i've been saying
lately is that it's not just
that the democrats and the media and
their big tech cohorts that it's not
just that they lie right we know that
they lie it's that they lie about
everything
and i really mean it at this point they
lie about every single thing
males are females 3.5 trillion equals
zero
we don't have a problem at the border
the vaccines are working as promised
they lie about absolutely everything and
what they seem to forget is we now have
videotape this is a new thing i did not
know about this this morning i said to
connor is there a way we could prove
that these people are liars and he said
we have video tape dave and we're going
to show video and i said all right let's
try it so first we're going to show you
here this is representative sheila
jackson lee of houston she is a
progressive thus a liar and here she is
talking about what's happening on our
southern border
let me pronounce to my friends that the
border is both sovereign and secure it
is obviously subjected to
biased and unfair narratives for
political purposes
it's both sovereign and secure well
we've got two videos for you here's
sovereign
and here is secure this is a wild
situation to see from the air we
reported earlier that the faa grounded
our fox news drones we cannot fly those
well the troopers with texas dps are
kind enough to let us go up in their
helicopter with them to get a look at
the situation at this bridge right now
take over 11 000 mike mexico into del
rio right here and they are waiting
underneath the international bridge
waiting to be processed by border patrol
look at the massive people down there
this time two days ago there were just
over fourth house damn right here to
walk across the rio grande and enter the
united states illegally put up to
the rio grande right here in a moment
this is uh
let's say you had a house
or an apartment i'm gonna go out on the
assumption that you watching this right
now you might live somewhere you've
maybe you're a homeless person and
you've been given a free phone by our
good governor gavin newsom here in
california imagine if there were
thousands of people standing outside of
your structure whatever it might be
whether it's a shack or a house or an
apartment or a condo
and they were trying to get in and then
occasionally you pushed them out and
then they kept coming
and then they were strolling over and
they were taking stuff and they were
rampaging through and imagine there was
also you know supposedly this crazy
pandemic and they weren't wearing masks
and you know they weren't vaccinated
they weren't social distancing and all
of those things would you call that
sovereign and secure
they're gaslighting all of us they are
extraordinary liars
so sheila jackson on this thursday
september 30th 2021 you are my liar of
the day and trust me it was not easy we
had about five other videos of
progressive lunatics let's play that
ayanna presley thing next monday all
right i mean these people
are
psychotic lunatic crazy people there's
no other way to say it and we have to
disconnect from them but i think i'm
going to get to that in one of the one
of the q as we're about to get to one
more thing before we do that i want to
talk to you guys about relief band you
know isn't all the news about vaccine
mandates making you nauseous god knows
it's making me nauseous we've all
experienced that horrible feeling
whether it's car sickness the result of
one too many after a night out with
friends or even from the anxiety of
accidentally landing on cnn while
channel surfing my god nausea can ruin a
day force us to change our plans in the
most severe cases it can make us unable
to function for those of you who can
relate i've got great news you can check
out relief band relief band's the fda's
number one cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the products 100
drug-free non-drowsy and provides
all-natural relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed relief
band stimulates a nerve in the wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick
relief band is worth trying for the
anxiety benefits alone it'll bring you
peace of mind and help you not worry
about nausea again as the world's
opening back up sort of
don't let the fear of nausea keep you on
the sidelines right now relief band has
an exclusive offer just for my audience
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code ruben you'll get twenty
percent off plus free shipping and a no
questions ask 30 day money back
guarantee so head over to r
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com
and use promo code ruben to get 20 off
plus free shipping and now back to me
all right let's roll right into the
questions we got a whole bunch here i
will get to as many as possible
antoinette says as we come closer to the
one-year anniversary of the 2020
election where do you see the country
heading
towards
well
hell frankly um yeah we're in a lot of
trouble we are really in a lot of
trouble you guys know this i try to do
this show with a smile on my face i try
to spin things positively i try to give
you the silver lining i'm trying not to
make you outraged i'm trying to you know
not
attack people who don't deserve to be
attacked all of that stuff but but we
we are
we're in trouble we're in trouble i just
see no other way to to look at it i was
actually at a party last night here in
l.a and virtually every single person
there was talking about
leaving mostly leaving la but leaving
california but there were plenty of
people there who had left already who
had come back for this event that i went
to and they were much happier in other
places like we we seemingly are in the
midst of this national divorce
you know i can tell you on the
california front um just because that's
where i am i mean look at the two things
that have happened since the recall
failed and obviously it was it was a
disaster right the two things that have
happened since then two or three days
later
they decide that in la if you go to
restaurants they're going to have a
vaccine mandate and you're going to have
to prove you're vaccinated they decided
that two days after even though covid
numbers have completely bottomed out
here if i'm not mistaken the week before
michael you can correct me on this if
i'm wrong the week before the week
basically during the uh recall one
person in la died of covid um so
they they just loved power so not only
did that happen but then just a few days
ago gavin newsom announced that we're
going to have mail-in ballots in
perpetuity in perpetuity and we talked
about it when you showed your envelope
if you were doing a mail-in ballot all
you have to do is show it to a light or
your iphone
flashlight and you could see who someone
voted for so you could have seen if they
selected for recall or not and whether
they voted for larry elder or not or
whatever it might be um that in and of
itself doesn't mean that there's fraud
but they're doing everything they can to
make nobody trust the system nobody
trusts the system uh right now in la
thanks for that uh la is averaging two
deaths a day
uh because of covid it's about 80 and
sunny every day in l.a we are i'm
watching when i go to the supermarket
these masked morons
just it's just extraordinary it's just
extraordinary but anyway i don't want to
make this specifically about kobe your
question is we're almost a year
from the election and like where's this
all heading right now it's not heading
anywhere good right like we are seeing
the democrats and biden and it's really
obama behind him and and the ideas of
communism and marxism and collectivism
and just huge government we're going to
take money and 3.5 trillion equals zero
boys and girls all the stuff all the
stuff it's all bursting forth nothing
seems to be working properly but
that all said
the silver lining is that humans
freaking find a way right it's like jeff
goldblum
in jurassic park life finds a way and
humans have been through communism and
we've been through nazism and we've been
through
socialism and all the ideas the bad
ideas of the past and we always find a
way right and and maybe always find a
way it's like a lot of people die in
that process too and it does seem like
everything's getting worse and it seems
like not only your vaccine mandates you
know
being pushed on everybody but they're
not going to want people to be able to
work if you're not doing what they say i
got an email from somebody i'm getting
so many emails right now from people
about vaccines
and what their how the mandates are
affecting them i got an email yesterday
from somebody who's a hospital
administrator who has worked at home for
the last two years in his basement he
has not been to the hospital in two
years he was already working at home
before lockdown started it wasn't even
because of covet he had decided to work
remotely
two years in his basement he is now
being laid off he is now being laid off
even though
he doesn't work at the hospital right
this is absolutely extraordinary and
completely out of control
and actually i think some of the other
questions are going to get to it but i i
sense we're in the midst of some
national divorce
but the silver lining is that people
hopefully whoever remains that is still
thinking for themselves and i know you
guys are out there and i meet these
people every day and i hear from you
guys every day it's like our ideas are
being refined and our are being they're
being challenged so we're it's making us
all think more clearly about what we
believe and what kind of life we want to
live and where we should live in all of
those things so the big system is awful
right now but there's ways to pilfer
goodness
and clarity through that that's what i'm
trying to do i think that's what my my
team is trying to do i hope that's what
you're trying to do
but look if they want to shut down the
government now and they think 3.5
trillion equals zero and all that shut
down the government go away i don't need
you people we'll be okay without you uh
tallay says with the current vaccine
mandate included in the democrats budget
bill that the republicans are
threatening to block by filibuster
what do you see as the honest condition
of relations between red states and blue
states being in 2022 and 2024 do you see
any avenue for healing or is it just
going to get worse i mean that's very
much in line with the first question
but i sense it's just going to get worse
it's just going to get worse there's a
really unbelievable video going around
viral right now on twitter
where one of the groups that's trying to
make sure that desantis doesn't remain
governor of florida because he kept the
state open and left things up to choice
and you know let individuals make
decisions for themselves they have this
ridiculous video uh sort of a parody of
the movie the purge
trying to attack
uh desantis for talking about things
like choice talking about things like
the constitution and freedom and that we
can't solve all your problems we being
the government obviously and it's like
that disconnect between someone that
believes the government should fix all
these things that disconnect between
if you think the two that you know a
year and a half later that now vaccine
mandates for everybody and forcing
companies to tell their employees that
you better get injected with something
or you're gonna get fired like if you
think that that's good well we don't
have a lot of middle ground on that
right we don't
and and so i do think things will just
continue to get separate and get
separate and get separate which again by
the way that's what the federal is the
federalist system allowed for that's the
way we were set up that the states were
supposed to handle most of this stuff
but it will always come down to and i
discuss this with with tucker carlson
and many of my other guests it will
always come down to that the red states
will be okay with that basically the red
states will say hey we're going to take
care of business we're going to take
care of our houses right we're going to
get our [ __ ] in order and the blue
states are going to go no no no no no no
you can't get your [ __ ] in order we want
that [ __ ] we want your productivity
because new businesses will be built in
red states and the blue states well
they'll just crumble because they're
they're going to get people who will not
be experts in things they are gonna
they're gonna care more about diversity
than than education or medicine or
science or any of those things and it's
just gonna crumble and crumble but one
other thing on this real quick
which is that in the 3.5 trillion dollar
spending bill there is some caveats
where if companies don't force their
employees to get injected they could be
fined as much as seventy thousand
dollars a day and it compounds day after
day after day it's unclear what size
companies that would be and everything
else look i've got a small production
company here with a couple employees
imagine the psychosis that you would be
under to believe that it would be my
right to tell people who i work with who
are sitting in this room right now yes
you must get injected with something
otherwise i'm going to fire you like
what right would i have to say that to
them that that's absolutely insane i
thought we were against slavery i mean
call me old school guys but i'm against
slavery you guys aren't my slaves right
i have no right to tell them what they
can do with their bodies what they
should do with their bodies and tell
them what they should be injected with
if you aren't feeling well don't come to
work all right can we agree on that
all right that's it let's move on
sally says do you think that the vaccine
mandate is just a way to eliminate the
free thinkers from schools military and
medical community and will it backfire
yes i do it's it's becoming very clear
american airlines is firing uh thousands
of people right now uh not only pilots
but you know people that work on the
ground at the airports they're firing
all sorts of people we know that that
psychotic lunatic i mean i have no other
way to describe these people at this
point right
the the governor of new york who again
nobody voted for right she stepped in
once new um newsome they're all the same
actually once cuomo went out
you know talking about how they're
getting rid of about 80 000 health care
employees and they're going to replace
them with the national guard because
they're not vaccinated these people who
we were told were heroes for a year and
a half these people who've put it all on
the line to make other sure other people
are safe and then some bureaucratic
[ __ ] who's just what nobody voted for
steps in and says we're gonna fire you
people they are trying to destroy
everything you really need to understand
this the communists the marxists the
democrats it's all the same thing and
maybe we need just a better catch-all
word for all of it they are trying to
destroy everything and they're doing it
quite well so don't think you know i
think there's sort of a meme out there
that either oh they they still think
they're doing the right thing or or
they're just idiots or something like
that and it's like no
if you don't think this stuff is
coordinated that they are trying to
bring down the economy they are trying
to to wreck everything like it is it's a
year and a half later guys
so yes i think they are we know we know
that they are trying to get rid of free
thinkers from the military in the
medical community and everywhere else
right we know it you don't have to you
know they'll hear me say it you know it
because
by saying okay you have to get
vaccinated for this again even if you're
young and healthy and you had covid and
you have antibodies and all that stuff
well those are the people who are
thinking about the world clearly they're
going well wait a minute i'm 25 i'm in
the military i'm fit i eat well i take
care of myself i had covid so i have
some antibodies i'll get tested when
need be etcetera etcetera you're the
free thinker and they're saying to you
you're out so they want people who bow
forever i have a torn acl on my left
knee i can't bow for that long
patty
says
desantis has stated he's not running for
president in 24 if he doesn't and trump
can't convince him to run as vp and if
trump runs again who do you think will
be a good running mate on the gop ticket
well first off
you guys know my feelings on this i
think desantis would be the best
fit i think he has fought the machine
and done it pretty freaking well for a
year and a half i think he has enough of
the trump energy i think he has the
right ideas i think he's you know i
think he's 43 years old or so he served
in the military like this is the guy
that it should be if he does not
um then
they're gonna have to make some
decisions because there's a whole group
of other people that i think are quite
decent i think nikki haley obviously is
decent i think tim scott is decent i
think a whole bunch of interesting
people could get involved that's one
thing um but your question really was if
desantis doesn't and sticks with florida
which good for florida if he doesn't
right um he may just not want to you
know bite that thing off like so if
trump runs then who's a good running
mate i think tim scott would be
interesting i think nikki haley would be
interesting i think crenshaw would be
interesting i think kansas owens would
be interesting i think that there's
plenty of people uh there's probably
some names that we don't even know about
yet um i'm hearing from from a lot of
people that trump does plan on running
and it's like
you know on one hand it's like we should
move on from that right like we should
move on for it just just because he also
is older at this point
you know biden obviously has cognitive
problems trump is fine but like it's
just like we should just move on from
that generation right like maybe gen x
45 year olds to 55 year olds should have
a chance to do something so much of
what's wrong with everything right now
is that you've got these people in their
late 70s early 80s up to dianne
feinstein 137 that they're just hanging
on and they as if they could solve the
problems that they created right and
that's not to say all older people are
bad i like older people i really do
cocoon great movie love the golden girls
okay but these people should not be in
charge of everything you don't want
sophia petrillo running the fed uh but
these people just refuse to get out of
the way so the the republicans are going
to have uh i think a very wide swath of
people and just to throw back to
something that i was saying during the
presidential election that was one of
the reasons i really wanted trump to win
i felt if we could get a second term of
trump it would so break the system that
was ready that was like shaking right
the system was just shaking and shaking
and freaking out that then after trump i
thought the republicans would have the
widest tent possible of candidates all
of the he would have broke the media he
would have broke the machine drain the
swamp if we could have just got four
more years of it but alas that didn't
happen and uh here we are
cooper says how badly do you wish it was
the start of august again
you know
this has been a weird one for sure out
of the five years that i've done the off
the grid august um
you know in some ways because of i told
you guys when i left on july 31st i had
just been banned by twitter because i
said vaccine mandates were coming i'm
pretty sure i was right on that uh we
announced the pre-sale of don't burn
this country it went to number one on
amazon so like i went out in a blaze of
glory it was like i've lit the match i
was like [ __ ] and i'm out of here and
the next morning we were on a plane to
the rainforest so it was such a
spectacular month i felt great you know
just yesterday uh we showed a clip of my
comeback show with adam carolla or i
guess two days ago when i was predicting
that i'd know nothing about the new
governor of new york um but i'm guessing
she's going to be far worse and further
left and everything and i looked at the
video and i was like man i looked pretty
damn great like i felt refreshed and
like my body was like tight and i was
like alive and like all that stuff i'm
feeling pretty good right now too but
like not the same way after a month um
and then since i've been back you know
the first two weeks it was like this
let's give everything we got to the
larry elder thing and i did and it was i
felt kind of i i was excited for the two
weeks and then afterwards there was
definitely a letdown it was uh
you know we had a whole talk with my
whole team about the future and you know
like
it's been kind of weird now everything
feels very up in the air and everything
else um you know but your question is do
i wish it was the start of august again
not really because i love this i believe
we're doing something important and
relevant and we just got to keep going
so even for those moments when i'm
frustrated and i'm like man they're all
liars and we got to show this [ __ ] again
and fight it it's like
this is it like we either got a chance
or we don't and i i just believe that we
do so uh you know another august will
roll around and until then we'll just
keep going and my life is pretty good we
eat good food we take the dog for a walk
you know we're watching downton abbey
again i got nothing to complain about
except for the communists that are
trying to get me um nate says how do you
get people to care about truth if it
doesn't fit their world view it's like
that's the that's the gajillion that's
the 3.5 trillion question nate um i
don't know it is very
very hard to do it because even when you
show
sort of a brainwashed lefty who watches
cnn and new york times when you show
them oh you know they had to retract
this story and they made up that story
and you know the russia thing was really
through the clinton campaign and brett
kavanaugh was not a serial rapist and
all the stuff that you guys know it's
like it's still it's this is why it has
something to do with belief i i and i
really believe this now
that if you don't humans have to believe
in something humans must believe in
something whether whether they realize
it or not and we all believe in
something even though the hard core
atheists believe in something they do
and when you take that belief
and you hide it and you repress it and
everything else you start believing in
just what is here and now and you start
believing oh the news said this and this
person did this and that's why they're
all sort of all hysterical and when you
present them with information that's
counter to that it feels like their
world view is falling apart because
they've put their whole world view in
just this stuff that's happening now
this fake nonsense with the news and
everything else and that's why if you
believe in time-tested things if you
believe
in let's say it's the stories of the
bible and whether you believe them
literally or figuratively or as
metaphors or
allegories whatever like if you believe
in something outside of yourself
something about the human experience
that over time we've taken good stuff
we've made new stuff and we keep moving
forward um if you believe in that you'll
be calmer and more decent and then when
new information comes to you you can
compare and contrast that with
whatever's happening in the world right
like with the stuff that you've learned
in the past and then you won't be so
hysterical and that's why i have so
consistently found in these last five
years that when i meet conservatives or
just whatever you want to call it again
that right people something you talk to
them about virtually anything and
they're okay to discuss it and nobody
gets up from the table screaming
throwing things telling your
you're a nazi or anything else they kind
of are just like i don't agree with that
you know we could keep talking you know
whatever and of course there are always
you know exceptions to those things um
but it has something to do with belief
joe says how is new york city and what
has changed most about it since coveting
since your childhood uh so as i think
most of you guys know i was born in
brooklyn in 76 before it was like
hipster brooklyn when it was still old
school brooklyn lived there for my first
couple years i grew up in long island
which is the suburbs of new york city
and then i moved to new york city in
2000 right after college basically so i
was in new york city for 9 11 and then i
lived there for about 13 years until i
moved to la in 2013 so i've really only
lived in new york and in california and
new york city i had great grandparents
and
my grandma lived in new york city and a
lot of extended family in new york city
everyone has either a lot of them are
dead but everyone else has fled at this
point i do have one distant cousin still
in new york city um but new york city is
weird uh we spent a week in new york
city and you know midtown which used to
be just teaming with people and that was
what new york city was all about and if
you can make it here you can make it
anywhere like that thing everyone
jaywalking smacking into each other
people pushing carts and yelling and
fighting and
the hot dog guys and you know every
person of every color and persuasion
everything else like that thing in
midtown from say like i don't know about
30th
to like maybe high 50s
uh more on the west side like a lot but
even eastside too grand central like
that it's very light there and there's
police everywhere every corner like four
or five policemen standing there a car
with lights like barricades and things
like that's very very creepy
that being said i saw way less people
with masks than i thought most people a
huge percentage of people i would say 90
percent of the people were not wearing
masks and when you went to the more
residential areas so i went back to the
upper west side where i used to live i
went down by chinatown and and little
italy and when you go to places like
that that's a little more touristy down
there but there was life the streets
were full you wouldn't have really known
that there was a problem and as i said
the other day if you walked into stores
nobody said anything about a mask at
least to me
one restaurant that we did go out one
night i went out with douglas murray and
greg gutfeld and my brother
and uh they did want to see a vaccine
passport but then about nine o'clock the
doorman walked away and people were
coming and going like it's all just like
this silly game but basically i would
say i was pretty freaking enthused about
the city and and that really made me
realize when i came home to la like that
contrast where l.a it's like everyone
here is still a clone and people are
masking while walking their dogs a huge
percentage of these people and in new
york there's still like a fighting
spirit like that that old-school new
york like don't f with us spirit and
that was really great to see really
great to see
storm says there was a city assembly
meeting last night for another mass
mandate and three people were arrested
do we need to get comfortable with the
idea that we will be getting arrested
for protesting for our rights so i'm not
sure of the specifics of of where you're
talking about
um but quite possibly you know there's a
lot of really horrific videos coming out
of australia specifically where people
are literally walking their dogs people
are just walking out of their apartment
complexes and being assaulted i mean
full-on assaulted tackled to the ground
kicked punched by police officers that
are supposedly protecting the public and
keeping us safe from a pandemic there's
a really horrible video of a police
officer choking on him and she's choking
you know he's choking a woman in the
name of health right like in the name of
oh we don't want you to catch covet
where you might choke on phlegm so we'll
just you know choke you with our hand um
but that's happening in australia you'll
never see that on
cnn why is that why wouldn't they show
that that there's you know upheaval in
australia because people are fighting
for their rights why why don't they show
you about the churches that are being
closed in canada and the protests that
are happening over there why
i'm gonna have to think about that can
you make a note of that i'm gonna have
to think about that one a little bit
um so we may have to get uh used to the
idea that good decent people are gonna
have to
protest i would always say protest
peacefully right we're gonna have to
protest peacefully and we're gonna have
to go out and about our lives and and
the only thing we can do and this is why
i believe in bottom up and not top down
is that if enough good people say no no
we're not gonna do this i'm a police
officer and i'm not gonna choke a random
woman for walking her dog
you know i'm a restaurateur and i'm not
going to deny someone service
you know a young healthy person service
just because they don't have a vaccine
man they card or whatever it might be
that's the only way we get out of this
that's the only way we get out of this
and that's why if the government wants
to shut down bye-bye
good
don't let the door hit you on the way
out uh jill says why do you think biden
got a third jab and do you think that
background was actually the white house
so in case you're not sure what jill's
talking about we've got some pictures
here
that's a stage and joe biden was on a
stage that is not the white house that
picture leaked later but they staged
this as if he was getting a picture
getting his injection his booster shot
uh at the white house but as you can see
it is clearly not i mean we're in
kayfabe we're in cafe do you guys know
what kfabe is kfabe
k-a-y-f-a-b-e
is what uh professional wrestling was
all based around the idea that you could
fake these things with predetermined
outcomes and you could cause all of
these people to have real emotions and
think that real things were happening
and as if the wrestling match wasn't
decided already
sort of pre-fabricated theater that
we're all playing around with this this
odd blend of reality and fantasy all at
once that's really what's happening
right now we are in the midst of some
giant wrestling situation and hulk hogan
himself would be proud of the k fave
that all joe biden is doing let's put
that picture back up for one more second
i don't think we have the close-up there
but you should find the close-up uh of
joe biden because he's got an extremely
hairy arm and i don't know if that's a
side effect of the coveted vaccine if it
can turn you into a werewolf but it's a
disturbing disturbing picture and i
leave it up to you we didn't show it to
you here because you know we want you
guys to we tell you things and then you
make the decision you should consult
with your wife maybe your doctor do i
want to see old joe biden's hairy arm
that's completely up to you just to be
clear i don't know if that picture was
actually in the white house on a set or
if it was just in another place
altogether but it's a set do you see why
that might be a problem
it's all fake it's all fake
sherry says we've seen a few slightly
negative main street news segments on
bite in the last few weeks why do you
think they're doing this well because
even for the most brainwashed even for
the most blue pill there has to be
the tiniest
thinnest veneer of objectivity by the
media so it's like look if trump was
president and we left afghanistan in
this disaster and the covid situation
was whatever they're claiming it is
right now
or the just every the border was a
freaking disaster like it is even though
you know we're told it's sovereign and
secure um if any of these things were
happening we'd be in the 12th
impeachment already okay so i think
there's a million reasons that they
could probably impeach biden or any i
don't even think biden's the president
and all that stuff you guys got it um
but why do i think that they're having a
couple articles that slightly leak out
negative towards binding it's because
they need it they they need you to be
somewhat oh you need to be able to say
but but i did see something in the uh
washington examiner that did say that he
was something something like they can't
completely lie to you about everything
at a hundred percent perfection because
it would be too clean right so they need
the crime scene to have a little bit of
blood around otherwise it would be too
obvious uh and i think we got one more
we're doing one more what do you think
yeah uh phillip says since college
football is back do you and david janet
support the same team or do you have
what we call in the south and interfaith
marriage also what's your opinion of the
f joe biden chance in these college
stadiums you know i really don't watch
current sports anymore we really don't
david went to penn state so he's a big
penn state guy and we'll occasionally
he'll find something if if they're
playing although it's been quite some
time on that um but obviously a great
football program um but i don't i just
don't watch current sports anymore um as
far as the f joe biden chance you know
what it's just fine with me just fine
with me people are frustrated and if
you're a you know in a group of people
and it moves you to chant f that guy
guess what you're allowed to do that in
the united states of america at least
for now all right like at least for
now
uh all right guys i gotta wrap because
uh a little later today at 2 30 pacific
i will be on prageru's will and amala
live which is their new is it a daily
show they're doing over there it's daily
a new daily show they're doing over
there and we're going to be talking
about a new documentary that i took part
in it's called restricted how big tech
is taking away your freedom which you
can watch right now at prageru
and it's you know it's all about the
stuff what has big tech done to us what
do they plan to do to us and what about
all the stuff we don't even know they're
doing to us and uh i share my thoughts
on those matters part two of my
interview with jack the soviets up we're
talking all about uh firing people
because of vaccines and everything else
and then we get into some stuff about
china and a whole bunch more the full
episode is up completely ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
and tomorrow it's an idw reunion
remember the idw we're a group of about
a group of about 20 or so people from
all over the political spectrum we tried
to solve problems and it pretty much
fell apart i think there's several
reasons for it and a lot of people just
kind of went off the deep end but a
couple people are still fighting for the
right things well we're doing a little
reunion we got gad sad we got michael
shermer and i believe
we have peter bogosian is that not not
confirmed not confirmed but if not we
will have a third member of the idw
tomorrow that'll be our friday show uh
that's it for me uh have a good day
everybody and uh
you know get out there see what happens
okay goodbye